el presidente de costa de marfil anunció
este sábado que lohan gbagbo su antiguo
rival político y predecesor había
recibido un indulto presidencial
para fortalecer la cohesión social
primero un decreto que otorga el indulto
presidencial al señor lobo también
solicite que se descongelen sus cuentas
y se paguen sus rentas vitalicias
atrasadas
el indulto se otorgó de cara al
aniversario 62 de la independencia del
país y es parte de los esfuerzos de
reconciliación antes de las elecciones
de 2025 el ex presidente gbagbo regresó
a la cosa de marfil al año pasado
después de ser absuelto en 2019 por la
corte penal internacional por presuntos
crímenes de guerra cometidos en 2011
después de que estalló una guerra civil
quien mató a unas 3.000 personas al
negarse a reconocer la derrota electoral
del actual líder uattara en las
elecciones presidenciales un año antes
el ex presidente también fue condenado
en ausencia por el saqueo del banco
central de los estados de áfrica
occidental tras la crisis electoral pero
desde que regresó a costa de márfil no
ha sido encarcelado por estos cargos y
mantuvo un perfil bajo